We are going to be doing
another live podcast
at the Wiltern Theater.
Did we ever tell you about this?
I don't think you did,
but, yeah.
Yeah, well we are.
Ok, cool.
And you're gonna be there.
Oh cool, okay.
Yeah (laughing).
That sounds fun.
You're gonna realize while you're on stage
that you're doing a podcast.
Oh.
That's how addled you are
now that you have twins.
Yeah.
Just, "Huh, what, oh,
yes, well hello audience."
Yeah.
Yeah, May 4th, Wiltern Theater.
We are gonna be doing
another live podcast.
The first one we did was such a blast.
We've got a great surprise guest.
Mm.
Very, very excited about this show.
It is sold out.
Oh.
But, you can follow
@teamcoco for free tickets.
That's cool.
Yeah, so, come and see us.
And it's all being made possible
by the good people at Chevrolet.
I was wondering why this
Chevrolet logo was behind you.
You know what?
Initially-
Yeah.
I just put up the Chevrolet logo
because I think it's a nice logo.
Oh, okay (laughing).
And, I didn't even know
that Chevrolet was involved.
I've always thought as auto logos go,
Chevy has the best one.
Oh, that's nice.
I just think it's beautiful.
It's absolutely gorgeous.
It's cool.
Yeah, and I've always had
the Chevy logo in my bedroom,
my living room.
(laughing) Okay.
I'm just a fan.
And, I have to say, I
am a fan of Chevrolet
because, first car,
my first memories are
my dad driving me around
in our 1963 Chevy Impala.
Oh, that's cool.
Yeah, it was blue and the
steering wheel squeaked.
They don't squeak anymore.
No.
Chevy took care of that issue.
But, I remember that really well.
I remember my dad driving
me and me sitting there.
It was a bench seat, really cool.
We had that car forever.
That's cool.
And so, yeah.
And, I'm excited.
Chevy has been a trusted
name in transportation
for 100 years.
No.
Yes.
Okay.
I mean, cars have only
been around like 70 years,
I think for the first 30-
No.
Yeah, Chevy was building chairs
and stuff and putting wheels on them.
(both laughing)
With a rope in front.
Yeah.
That people would just pull.
Yeah, and they said "Just trust me,
it's gonna be a car eventually."
Thanks Mr. Chevy.
Yeah, thank you Mr. Chevy.
They've always been there for you
and for the people.
And you know, I'm also excited because,
as you know, I'm a big
fan of electric vehicles.
Yes, you are.
EVs.
And Chevy is coming out
with an incredible line
of electric vehicles.
That's great.
And that makes me happy.
I mean vehicles for
whatever your budget is,
they have a vehicle for you.
Whatever your needs are,
whatever stage you are in life,
they have a vehicle for you.
Are they gonna have an electric truck?
Well here's what I wanna talk about.
They are, I'm glad you asked me that.
My favorite truck name of all time.
Yeah.
You can't beat it, Silverado.
You have to say it like that?
You do, Silverado.
That's like the best.
And you know, I'm sure
they have pitch meetings
where they sit around and
they think what truck name
hasn't been used?
The other car companies, they
just must be going crazy.
Yeah.
That they missed out
on Silverado.
It's a good one.
Yeah, 'cause when you say like,
"I'm headed over to your place."
"Really, what are you coming in?"
"Silverado."
That's the coolest.
Right?
It's even cooler now
the that it's gonna be electric.
Yeah, I think that's coming out next year.
Wow, that's cool.
I just think that's an
amazing name, Silverado.
Yeah.
I'm excited.
Our thanks to Chevrolet
for making this possible.
May 4th, Wiltern Theater, and as I said,
it's sold out but follow
@teamcoco for free tickets.